Jeff we're here this morning for the
latest screening of your book which is a
conversion to film The Diary of a Wimpy
Kid Part 3 Dog Days now of course I've
got to ask you how much of a Wimpy Kid
were you and you're that age I think
that was an average kid I had really
wimpy moments in the second Wimpy Kid
movie Greg hides out from his swim team
coach and wraps himself in toilet paper
and I have to admit I did that when I
was a kid too
are there any experiences in this latest
film and the books it's based on that
you had as a kid as well there's a
really fun scene in the beginning of the
3rd Wimpy Kid movie Dog Days where Greg
has to go through a crowded men's locker
room and I remember being a kid and
being taken through the men's locker
room you know the men's changing area
and it was just the most horrifying
experience and I never was I couldn't be
prepared for it by my father
kind of cathartic than having written
these books and getting these
experiences out onto paper yeah it's
been really fun I feel like I've sort of
captured my own childhood in a way or a
version of it and I've gotten to tell my
stories to the world and that's been
wonderful and you've got a small role
haven't you in the latest film Dog Days
tell me a little bit about that
I've got a small non-speaking role in
Dog Days I'm the worst actor in the
world so it's good that they didn't put
a microphone on me as well but I play
Holly Hills his father which is totally
implausible because Holly Hills is as
precious you know beautiful little girl
and I you know I I can't I don't know
where the DNA came from where the
genetic code came from from me to be her
father
how do you feel about how the books have
been transferred to the big screen
because obviously on the third one now
aren't we I think it's really fun seeing
the books get translated into film
because you know when you're doing that
application you never know how it's
going to come out but I think that they
really did a good job of casting these
films and for telling stories that are
really authentic to childhood and what
didn't make it from the books into dog
Dave but their only thing he thought oh
I'd love to have seen that in there
there's a scene in my book Dog Days
where Greg and Rowley mow the neighbor's
lawn and they do a terrible job of it
they start this business a long care
business and they do a terrible job of
it and I wish that gotten to
was that an experience she had as a kid
doing those kind of joke
I remember being a kid and I wanted to
start a lawn mowing service but my
grandmother whose law and I mowed
wouldn't give me a recommendation so so
my my business was a non-starter
that's quite tough isn't it with the
Family Code through you that it is
indeed it is now I knew that when you're
writing the book you kind of switch off
for any other kids books or young adult
literature but I know that you like to
listen to the different audiobooks and
one of the things that you like to
listen to is Game of Thrones what is it
about that that you enjoy listening to
your right and the wimpy kids and what
kind of world does it take you into an
inspiration does it give you maybe when
I Ella straight my books I like to
listen to lots and lots of audiobooks
and one of the series that I've listened
to is Game of Thrones what I really like
about Game of Thrones decides this giant
complete world you know it's this whole
universe that the author has created so
I think I'm very inspired by that that
somebody's imagination could run that
deep and how about have you seen the TV
series as well what do you think of that
I have seen the TV series it's a little
violent for my taste but it but I think
it's really well done one queen look
forward to the next book how many books
will there be and what about future
films I'm hoping to write at least 10
Diary of a Wimpy Kid books and as for
feature films I think that the kids in
the first trilogy of movies have
probably aged out of these rolla's so I
think they're for to do more live-action
films will need a new cast but you never
say never you never know we could film
another one with this cast as well but I
think that Greg's nook next life is as
an animated character and so I'm eager
to work on a holiday special for TV
would you be involved in kind of some
the animation for that as well would you
be kind of stepping back and just
advising how would it work if we do an
animated feature I'll be working with
the animators to get the looks of the
characters right and to get the
animations right and I'll also be
writing it
and when could we look forward to that
do you think I'm hoping that we can get
our act together by by next year holiday
season hopefully fingers crossed and
will that take us into the next book of
the Wimpy Kid series and what can we
look forward to therefore in the
animated film the animated holiday
special will be based on Wimpy Kid 6
which is called cabin fever and as far
as the future of the series goes I'm
hoping to write at least three more and
you never know what kinds of situations
Greg's is kind of find himself in a
great reception as well for the latest
book haven't you can you tell us a
little bit about that and the kind of
feedback you're getting from a fan so
far my seventh book Diary of a Wimpy Kid
the third wheel just came out around the
world and I've been touring the UK and
I've gotten to meet tons of fans
thousands of fans so it's been very
gratifying to see that people still care
about the series that is still relevant
and that it's making kids laugh what's a
favorite question the kids have to ask
you about the series kids always want to
know if I'm going to be writing more
books and I am and that's great I think
that kids want to know that it's not
over so I'm really excited that that
there stood up still that enthusiasm
what kind of advice do you have for
young kids you'd like to maybe get into
writing books like diary Wimpy Kid
my advice for young kids who want to be
writers or cartoonists illustrators is
to keep working at and keep working I
think it takes about ten years to really
become an expert at something and I'd
really advise kids to just keep
developing and nurturing their ideas and
I noticed when you were sketching and
writing your ideas down for one be kid
you were kind of a little bit worried
that you didn't have enough ideas he
started writing really really small and
you know pregnant you I mean did you
ever in visit you know you'd be on your
soon tense book and they'd all be made
into films as well an animated series
I never code for seen any of this I
think you know I just wanted to be a
cartoonist to get my work seen by
somebody and so I never could have
imagined that it would become this
worldwide phenomenon
and that I'd you know be in this
position so it's it's unreal to me
and can we look forward to maybe once
wimpy kids finished and we look forward
to other series from your other book
single books maybe I hope I have another
idea in me I think I'm a good gag writer
so I think that I can tell more good
jokes that I just need a really good
hook that doesn't feel contrived we look
forward to that of course Dog Days as
well on DVD and all the future animated
series possible live-action ones and of
course many more books to come thanks
death yeah thank you very much
you